now check does he want to trade i would  i don't think he needs to trade bishops  he could trade bishops actually  you know trading is okay and  now bring the king yeah that's fine  that's very clear play by lavon i mean  it looks like he's got a plan in his  mind and he's just executing it  flawlessly he's not  uh he's not thinking about too many  options he says my rook is active europe  is stuck on eight i will trade those  bishop  your bishop is the only active piece my  king's gonna pick up the g6 pawn  and the g4 and the a7 pawn will decide  the game yeah i mean it's completely  winning  so can you look at magnus he's not happy  he's not happy danny  oh well i'm not surprised because this  is miserable  yeah i mean very looked like very nice  technique from levon actually because he  managed to  um control uh any counter play  so yeah and magnus resigns yeah  ah we've got i'm look i'm looking around  that is gigi love